hey guys yeah so this tutorial is
hands-on so if you please take off your
laptop they look great they I remember
they asked you to half anaconda so I'll
try to work with that even though I
don't use it but okay let's see how it
goes so for those that will follow I
will do some I will tell you some
installation really fast of the opencv
it should take about 2 minutes and then
I will introduce myself
in the in the meantime it should be
installing so let's do this so if you
can please go to that repository and in
github area on this PI data now we great
so let me do it also mean
yep so just more or less see if it loads
if not basically ok so installation
steps is gonna be one commander don't be
scared okay so now this one contain
stall basically okay so a normally open
CV for have all the functionalities of
open CV you need to compile it from the
binaries but for this tutorial you
you're not not going to be able to
follow just a little small part if you
use conduct but for everything else you
will be able for the instance and
interesting parts you will be able to do
it so okay let's try it oh please
first need to make sure kiddo okey so my
name is Rodrigo and I'm from Mexico and
I study physics and I did my PhD here in
the Netherlands theoretical physics and
quantum mechanics and I recently started
as a data scientist in ecology so let's
see and I'll be using this tool a bit
for fun we also have a demo a live demo
there in the in the stand you would like
to compares you to some famous stars so
I normally get mr. bean but maybe maybe
you get the Brad Pitt or something I
don't know okay so let's proceed here
you probably did this already so let's
see okay so for OpenCV if you later want
to use it so there are of course many
versions but normally you can do 3.0 3.1
and when you try to do face recognition
i will try to address those two just to
we're going to use three point one but
3.0 has it doesn't it breaks if it is
quite different what you do recognition
so just keep on in mind if later in your
house you want to just play with it okay
so it's going pretty slow of course but
the good thing is I already have it here
compiled of course for myself so let's
see so just make sure like of course
when you do it just make sure if you can
import this dot face then you're ready
to go
you basically have everything because
you have like open sea open CV has CV -
and then it has the normal packages but
for face recognition and machine
learning techniques you face your
connection to do CV to that face and if
you do that and three point one perfect
and the other one is still yeah pretty
slow okay so okay hopefully you guys
will do it a bit faster if somebody
already got it now more or less fifty
percent something that so will help you
okay so let's
so like them or dangerous stuff
okey-dokey so I hope it doesn't take
that much how much time okay so later if
you want to use the notebooks and I also
made an application within the you can
also in the repository where you can use
these we're going to use three different
methods to recognize faces and you can
use it look at the code and change stuff
whatever that's pretty nice and of
course the notebooks are available and
we'll talk about so we'll do this thing
okay but I will also try to explain you
how it works a little bit because well
it is some linear algebra and say in
quantum mechanics there's a lot so I
like it and okay so I'm gonna start
quotes okay so okay so the clicker yeah
of course so a bit about OpenCV is an
open source computer vision machine
learning software library and it has
wrapper for Python which is writing C
C++ originally so it works quite fast in
my opinion and you have many different
recognizers for face already trained
models for face for faces four legs for
a person so there you can look like in
YouTube for example and do open CV and
there's people that put in their car
already of course with some extra nicely
features and they already detect the
people like going through a receiver of
our core that's pretty nice okay and of
course if you get a really nice camera
or of course it works even better with
this camera but maybe not okay so okay
let's see okay so to this tutorial will
first learn the basics so we'll try to
do every there are other libraries that
you can do this but I will try to do
everything with with open CV and will
first learn how to manipulate some of
the basics of images and videos and then
we'll create something with it very
small but something and then
learn how to do the face detection
through OpenCV and we're going to build
our data set so let's see how that go so
I'm gonna need a volunteer for that
because of course if it's only myself of
course kind of recognize me
so maybe Marcel can can help me or
anyone so so good okay and then yeah
well then we'll build the model using an
open CV and this here is going to be
different for 2.0 3.1 and then we will
try to recognize the faces in a live
video feed and then I guess we will have
time because now I think I'll have an
hour and a half those three we will try
to do a classification having the
knowledge of what the eigenvectors are
and linear algebra so we'll try to
classify other type of objects like for
example I think what we will try to do
and I just did it yesterday so don't
expect too much but the theory is there
some heart disease data where they're
classified as the cancer is benign or or
in Spanish malignant no the other yeah
like bad or good they work anyway so
we'll try to do it and okay I hope more
or less okay so they we're going to
import numpy of course this this CV to
this is just to output the version
okeydoke perfect okay and of course I
import CV - and then the civet - version
is just to check just to double-check
because before I had 3.0 and then I need
to change things that I need to know I
needed to know which notebook was what
so okay okay so we're going to start
with the basics so we're going to take a
picture a pretty pretty simple so so for
this would use the video capture and for
this you just send an index 0 1 2 if you
have one camera two cameras the webcam
doesn't matter you have 5 6 doesn't
matter it will just create an object of
basically webcam and then you can read
from this webcam and it's basically what
it takes is a frame so in any returns if
I actually read it or not and of course
the frame and here will print just in
case it doesn't work
and then the last command okay the last
command is actually very important
because if you forgot to really forget
to release it and trust me it's a really
annoying and then you close your
application your camera will be still be
on but you cannot there's no way for you
to close it but to basically log out and
log in or kill it like from the process
so it's really annoying so don't forget
that command when you actually do an
application because here is not the real
problem where you when you create an
application if it crashes and it didn't
really didn't get to that command that's
yeah it's not good okay
okay though okay we took the picture
yeah but where where is this right okay
so open CV has its own thing to show
your pictures and and and for this it
shows like an external window and for
this because the external window is
interactive let's say we have to open
another thread that OpenCV already
provides you so we can handle whatever
events happen in the window without
stopping the events in the notebook but
normally you wouldn't have like if you
do an application and if you want
something to be running at the same time
the of course the window is running then
you do it but if not there's no reason
to do it okay and now very easy so we
declare basically a window here this one
and I just call it the PI data tutorial
and then you the you send a flag in this
case you just say window normal and it
just opens ooh anyway so that's a
picture pretty bad one okay anyway
so and basically you can just normal
means that you can expand it or stuff
doesn't really matter and if you if you
don't open the start window thread and
you close this your notebook will crash
and then you have to start over so don't
forget that threat okay okay and then
see we the white key just waits for you
to open to just hit a key and then you
close it and I really like this command
like when they are written like this
destroy all windows
that's pretty I really like it okay okay
so now so I am sure basically just
the frame that you just took right and
then then you send the same name of the
window and then that's it you can also
do for example Oh actually I think I
have it here yeah you can also do this
so remember this is your basics
and this is basically then the outer
size so right now I cannot make it
anymore
move it or anything but anyway but it's
the same thing the same the same idea
right okay so let's continue and please
any questions whatever I'm really open
for you to interrupt me please because
I'm not going to have this too much so
if you interrupt me I'll be good okay so
what what about wood in the note the
notebook right because well if you use
in the notebook we like let's use it
okay well the good thing is the frame is
an umpire right that's great and it's
great also because we can use it of
course in Nauvoo but it's also very good
for other stuff right because now you
can use basically everything on this and
it's just what makes it good so of
course we can use just map map plot live
and then it's played there and of course
you place it like a graph so that's
pretty awful and I think you can't
really cannot really see the difference
but let me just maybe if I just do it
again this takes better one
okay yeah
anyway you see my hair is like a little
weird it's like blue and something
really strange they're happening and
then okay so it's because OpenCV f well
maybe no I have no idea why they use BGR
instead of RGB yes quite annoying but
well you cannot do anything about it so
that's why it looks all so bad so for
that OpenCV also provides this type of
functions a cv to CVT color and you can
change from gray to BGR to RGB to
grayscale to hsv-2 also rgv and then the
other thing for transparency yeah you
can basically anything produce me okay
and now we just make it a bit better
right now it's the right color so it's
red so it should be and then we ticks
ticks off so okay anyway so continue ok
read and write images okay so for
written right images we just do I am
right and I am read pretty simple and
that you just send the path and numpy
array and then if you want these the
flags here if it's 1 0 or minus 1
depends if you want to read it in color
and gray scale or just unchanged if it
has an alpha Channel so that's
transparency okay so now okay well if if
OpenCV gets to the right in gbr that's
it save it in PGR because so that will
be really sucky and well doesn't that's
a good thing right
so you can see here yeah so the GBR
that's the one from OpenCV it's quite oh
it's the right colors and then of course
for reading the same thing you can just
do it again right and so within you can
see here that because I change it right
I changed this one but this is the
correct one so in RGB so within within
OpenCV everything is right so don't
worry about it
once you dump you dump it in a file or
whatever it comes back to the normal way
so it's just within it so we don't have
to
worry about it okay somebody can
following no not really
oh okay cool well that's great okay yeah
can I go a bit slower because I think
it's important it's a tutorial right
okay so anyway so this is what I was
saying so within open CV yeah I get its
onion in gbr but like the images and
everything is perfectly correct so don't
worry about it okay so this is a useful
function when I use to just define just
to print inside the notebook pretty
useful because I want to write that and
then we can also send a title so right
and then here in case the image is in
grayscale it automatically will put it
in grayscale okay um let's see you else
do we have to - - okie dokie
okay so now let's start taking a video
right so it's okay so I don't know about
this right but anyway yeah so see maybe
this way will be better yeah maybe I
don't know okay so let's see so it's so
it's the same thing
but now we don't release it right so
it's it's there it's capturing capturing
capturing and of course then I make this
command just to see if it if it handles
it because I yeah it's pretty useful
right now of course makes no difference
it's a bit to put it there doesn't make
sense but then to give a feedback
because then like I said sometimes it's
open because something crashed so it's
good to have a print that we implement
in a class later okay so again the same
thing oh so that's the whole idea right
you take of you take a frame you show it
you repeat you saw it repeat of course
and then you get a video okay so the
same stuff so we open again a window and
then we just do a loop and then we use
this useful command of wait key and then
that those are in milliseconds so 20
milliseconds it waits for pressing your
key and then it just basically renews
the window and let's see what happens
here yeah so let's me hello
okay
and anyway okay oh yeah much better
lightning okay good
okay so now that oh that the weird thing
that is there I don't know if you know
what it is but know that they they zero
times F F but it still convert it in
order to have the escape because escapes
27:4 if you want to just have a key
instead of any key before it was just
any key now escape and then we'll use it
for other letters but right now it's
just like that okay so okay so you see I
did its end release so if somebody is
following you will see that your camera
is still on and this is what I mean okay
so okay so we continue using it because
it's on I don't need to admit to open
again okay now we do it just within the
notebook and with a notebook we use this
useful function clear output right I
hope you know it but if not you just
clear output and you say that the white
true so it waits for the new output
another in order to replace it so pretty
simple okey-dokey okay and then don't
forget that yeah of course I'm pretty
sure if I don't put it there I will
forget it so good thing I put it there
okay what is oh it's not releasing you
see why not oh yeah oh yeah of course
yeah this is still running and I put so
a keyboard interrupt because there's a
difference from the window where you can
catch a pressing a key
well the notebook is always running so
if I press a key that basically doesn't
catch it because the so what I do is
just the keyboard interrupt so in the
notebook you just go to the to the other
mode and double I and then basically
that's it keyboard interrupt and if you
didn't do that again if you just close
it the Cameron Steel's on and then gives
you this problem so it's important to
catch it okay so we continue ok read and
write videos okay so similar to the
images now you have this video writer
for CC and that's what defines it
defines the codecs are you going to use
for your video so you
be shooting a video of your house or
you're shooting a video surveillance
video or something I don't know you want
to save it so this defines I will go a
little bit over what this is know in the
next slide and then you define basically
a container and this is container we're
going to put all your frames as fast as
you want and then you basically got a
dump that container basically into a
file okay so for the four CC you can
define all these types of things like x
width mg PG X - 16 - for all the
different you can go to this webpage and
then there has a full list of all the
codecs that you can use and okay so
let's see okay so now so I do this video
capture and I already have saved the
video for testing and it's an avi video
and if you see this video capture can
also the index but I can also just just
send a path to your video okay and then
it saves in the same way as if where's
the camera and then I print the video
it's open just to make sure it's working
and then the same thing about naming the
window you can also resize it as I do
here and then we do the exactly the same
stuff and if you see here I change this
just to now 4q so now you can use you
can use it later for if you want to
change let's say I will use it a bit
later so we can catch different keys if
you want to have different
functionalities or you may make a game
and then you would have this keys to
move around okay and so basically let's
see this video so I think remember what
was this video about oh yeah so this guy
that annoys the cab I found a pretty
funny that I don't have using it now you
seen it I don't know but then the cat
goes and it's pretty funny his reaction
later
yeah what the guys anyway so you see the
video is kind of finished and my
notebook is gonna crash basically let's
see and that's because I trying to read
every time right you can see that mm-hmm
it's trying to read so it tried to read
that there's nothing to read anymore
because the video finished right so for
that we can use this here of course
topic that we mentioned at the beginning
this one and you can also of course
change the frames within the thing here
so it provides you all again so now we
change it to a grayscale and now we're
going to flip it also you can do many
other stuff so let's see what this how
this works
yeah so this grain scale got flipped and
now as you finish of course miss Ghana
and that's going to crash because we're
using this feedback from well disco our
RIT and well you can let it finish but
do you want to laugh again I don't know
anyway so let's early finish just to see
it won't crash or anything okay and then
in the next one we will do it within the
within the of course within the notebook
but then we'll do something to the video
so I'm didn't crash everything good
perfect okay so now what we're gonna do
here we can also of course an umpire
array so then we can cut half of it or
throw in this case I think I'd throw a
third of it because yeah go ahead sorry
No yeah yeah
okay so anyway so yeah so let's just cut
one third of it and of course makes it
much better I mean pretty simple stuff
okay and then we will let's see okay so
keep our interrupts the same stuff if
you see the videos in the notebook of
course or much slower okay so now we're
we going we're going to record a video
and in OpenCV more or less like more or
less buys you to use this cut this roll
more or less so because you have to give
the frames per second so when you use
this key weight in the end the
milliseconds use this this this formula
and then your video will be more or less
as a real time movement so let's see
more or less so I think it's taking a
video of me yeah of course and then
let's display where is it
yeah yeah perfect okay so now it's the
video before so very simple very easy so
you want to do that stuff
okay so one of the things so this I use
avi of course and of course the same
thing for this oh yeah okay here and
then here yeah if you see I put 40
milliseconds and then I use that rule in
order to send the frames per second so
more or less it will be 45 right but so
that works
oh sorry 50 okay so we can do the same
thing of course then we do that to do
this of course works and everything okay
now just in case just I'm going to give
you a tip just think it's probably you
know what okay so if you try for example
that video that I just recorded with avi
of you try to put in HTML of course not
it's not going to work right and that's
it this is like a tip it doesn't work
because well at least these things here
because well basically mp4 will be the
way to go and that's why if you
to do that and then use it in your web
page or use it somewhere else
oh no you can code it with this one the
h2 h.264 and then the container and mp4
and if I do that then just close it okay
there so here it is of course
oh okay
so in captures all the yeah captures all
the images and for some of you go online
and try to convert this avi to mp4 it's
I don't know why they don't work well so
now you if you want to implement this in
a webpage you probably get a lot of hits
just to compare videos because they yeah
they don't work pretty well okay so you
can also have a lot of things to write
in to dry now in an image and we're in a
video you have created a line a
rectangle a circle and ellipse or just
put text in it and of course so this I
will just demonstrate something really
quick so let's just put a rectangle
right and then if you want just yeah
alright so pretty easy nothing
complicated about this okay pretty good
and that's basically just put text you
send the coordinates and stuff and the
rectangle is the same thing the
coordinates of both but it's basically
using the same thing
okay now this thing we're going to use a
mask now to we're going to work a little
bit with it I don't know if you're
familiar with the concept of a mask or
if you maybe some work before in
semiconductors where they use it to do
basically the chips when the the wafers
or if you're a graffiti artist where you
also use a mask yeah so anyway so let's
go and use it okay so in this case I
what I do is here I create this circle
in the mask the mask is completely black
and then they create this circle in a
white color so it then imagine just the
circle white and then the
everything else is black and then by
doing a bitwise operation over my actual
frame in the mask then you get of course
this thing where everything blocks so
wherever you put the white done it
well of course let it pass and that's
what I messed us okay so let's continue
okay so now handling Mouse events like I
said if you want to make interactive
window you can also say it like Mouse
callback where you send the name of the
window that will you define and then
just the callback function basically and
and then you define the function of
course and it has all kinds of things
like all for the mouse left button down
scroll and this is just a few I didn't
even put them all so you can or a care
if you want to create kind of a paint or
something like that or even better or
you can go ahead and do it it gives you
all the controls okay so what I'm gonna
do here is basically I create a mask I
believe oh no I just create circles with
my mouse so nothing special where I
basically just define the coordinates
that's the first so let's say you just
define like coordinates and stuff by
sending this circle and then just graph
the bands but then you can use whatever
you want right for this okay so let's
continue and then something maybe you
want to build something for kids or
something so you have a video there yeah
they discover the image behind right
you're like oh yeah hey there something
you can do a square of course and stuff
like that and whatever then and then of
course if you do the CV 2k for another
letter then you can change between him
between whatever you want and stuff I
mean it's not okay so let's see okay
well okay so so that was basically some
basic manipulation of the things so now
we will go to basically face detection
and this is basically the images that
are the functions that I did that would
in a previous notebook so nothing no so
try to go
quite fasten this so okay okay so the
face detection using a hard feature
basically case filters so this is what
the opencv uses to the tech faces I
don't know if someone of you have heard
of this algorithm before yeah okay so
try to go really fast with it okay so
the car features are all these squares
that you can see here right and then you
that you can rotate them or whatever it
just goes through the image and then
they large them rectangles the other way
the other way around and it just goes
inside and what it does it subtracts
whatever the sum of the pixel intensity
in the white sorry the black subtracts
to the white and then it gets you an
output and in this way recognizes some
of the features for example that the the
Kaveri of the ice is darker than the
nose and then also that the forehead
normally is sorry that the cheekbones
are a bit have more light normally than
the eyes and all these kind of features
and it's basically what it does is just
try say all of them
yeah and it outputs like yeah whatever
the field the main features are so now
if you if you do this for example even
in a 24 by 24 window and you take all
the possibilities of combinations that
gives you 160,000 possible features that
you can have so that's bit too much and
yeah and then of course every time you
apply of one of these you need to sum
all these pixel intensities so there are
different solutions and one is adaboost
in the one the other idea is integral
image and Alaba what it does also an
integral image first so normally you
will have to subtract all the pixels
from from the white to the black right
the other way one sorry but now instead
so at the beginning you define your
image and you do this operation you take
a point you take a point here and then
you do see let's say you do C minus a so
you see plus a B and C and B and D so
for example now so this is an example
here yeah so now for example you want to
know the
pixel intensity in this region right I
don't need to sum I don't need to sound
this anymore this is equal of course to
all the region in C and then plus a
minus the region here in B includes all
this and minus D in this now so every
point is defined as the sum of this
pixel intensities to their left and up
and if you do that then every time you
need to sum of these pixels you
basically have to do four numbers
instead of the whole region I think it's
quite simple and quite clever but maybe
it's just me okay so that's basically
what you reduce it every image to an
integral image and then adaboost so what
it does basically basically with a
linear combination well when I look out
at above a linear combination okay
and then so you have all these features
and of course some are more important
than others and just basically ranks
them and selects the best ones that you
can use and and then of course each of
these features becomes a weak classifier
but by doing the linear combination it
creates a strong classifier now right
okay and of course the bigger the Alpha
the more relevant the feature is okay
and then from these you take around
160,000 and then you can cut it I think
OpenCV I think or there or the viola
Jones uses around 6,000 features and
which are the most important okay so
questions no okay pray okay okay so you
still have 6,000 features and every time
you have an image you have to sweep
every feature for every size right so it
still steals a lot and this will be so
slow so for this solution is cascading
and cascading basically is this
so guys getting means you separate the
features in batches and then you send
you send certain batch to check to the
image and it says so that so you go the
most robust to the less robust and then
if the first discarded okay then throw
it away don't even check in the other
ones then the next step the next step so
of course you can use this idea in some
other in some other type of machine
learning
techniques of using different ones and
you know one is a like really good one
but then the other one the only checks
certain part of your of your data that
you can check just for the first one yes
you know I don't even don't even bother
for this for the second one just just
throw it away okay so for this OpenCV
uses thirty two stages and with ten
twenty five and like this and fifty
features and then by doing all this
obesity basically it's able to create a
recognizer of the object that you
basically train it with and of course
this idea is not only for faces many
people have used it for bananas
apparently for cars for phones for hands
I think for dogs also I've seen also for
like fruits so if you want to train the
algorithm for certain objects just go
ahead and do it okay so but OpenCV
provides you with all of this so
basically can they take the eyes with
glasses the left ear they either the
front leg
so apparently everything the right eye
and it has also different ones like
upper body and all this kind of stuff so
the one that we're going to use is this
frontal face underscore the alternative
okay okay now so the detector you create
a detector by passing the Cascade
classifier and you basically pass one of
these ones whatever you want they are to
to create the object and then basically
what it does you then the detector just
basically detect and you pass the image
and you pass certain like the scale
factor the minimum neighbor's minimum
size and flex this the scale factor
means how much do you want
so because it's checking and then
reducing and stuff is how much do you
want it to grow or or or or get little
stuff so let the recommended factor is
one point two if you do a like one point
one it gets a bit slow and the minimum
neighbors is of course how many
neighbors have to flag positive in order
to recognize the object okay
and the coordinates basically X Y width
and height that's what the returns so it
tells you let's say a square around the
object that you found basically okay
okay okay so let's just so right now
oh this is not gonna work I think maybe
if I do it's too bright I think it's
just one day yeah I think this will work
when the camera
okay just when the camera opens for the
first time it gets like like when you
wake up and there's a lot of light
similar to that so yeah so I have to
take a picture first so it let it open
and then it gets all these lining and
then it gets it back in the correct way
so let me see if I can maybe this way
would be better okay let's see if it
works okay so we have that image and now
we send it to the detector and then add
a scale factor 1.2 minimum neighbors the
minimum size of course what do we want
and so we pass the frontal face or
actually rename it but it is the
alternative the 1 and it passed the
detector and the detector just basically
the text when I pass the frame that I
just took in the previous slide and then
basically it will yeah so it tell me it
tells me yeah okay you detected one so
it's important to see what happens if it
doesn't detect anything what happens if
you detects one or two or stuff right so
what it detects if you the text one is
an umpire array then it gives you
basically if you detects five so it's
five rows of different coordinates in
this case it's just one so if I oh yeah
so let's say I go away yeah so now
returns a tuple and of course the length
is zero so if you see if you can apply
of course the length to a tuple or to a
number array so you can use this as to
differentiate if it if you use one or if
it found something or not so let's take
just two I think I need it later
let me see first okay okay so now like I
said it returned the the coordinates so
what I'm going to do is just going to
rub the a rectangle around my face using
the rectangle function so I just sent
the coordinates that the same recognize
recognize sorry the detection and method
sent to me and I just send it to a
rectangle and they say okay paint the
paint paint a rectangle pretty good and
okay and this
this is the thickness and is basically a
color and then of course the coordinates
and then just the frame where you want
to paint it in and we use the function
that we defined before pretty good okay
so we're gonna have some helpful
definitions because too much typing okay
so yeah so we're going to declare this
face detector and then the function just
detect very easy stuff and then find the
biggest object and then also this one
which is basically this is the most
helpful thing because then I don't
forget it if you just guess the object
gets the deleted is just by itself and
then of course captures so it's pretty
helpful stuff okay let's see
so we activate this that we do that okay
now we do it within and now basically it
follows me around just goes and says
okay I found you I draw the rectangle
I'm sorry that doesn't work yeah but you
can yeah if I go here yeah but you can
of course that's something and I yeah
you can work with it because you there
is a function that rotates and you
basically rotate it let's say ten
degrees every something and then it will
detect it and then you rotate also the
rectangle and then it just it goes back
so then basically even you with
something like that it will detect it
but it's just rotating there add that
for that I think it has certain angle so
for example it's a view here and then
maybe a little bit it goes away and goes
so it's not really good and if I go
completely of course that but there is
there is one there is one for the the
ones that I show you there is one for
sides but then you will have to check
you will you will have to check double
you'll have to create a detector for the
front and a picture for the side yeah
exactly there's also a detector for the
eyes for example so you can use that
also so you can combine a lot of stuff
so for example for the eyes it has a lot
of false positives so for that is used I
will talk about it later for alignment
like like if well you don't know what
this person is like that or stuff so if
you want to recognize the face the most
important one for my opinion one the
most important thing is to have a
normalized image similar to your
database or whatever and then of course
you use the eyes to rotate this thing
for example so pretty helpful okay so
here I am again again this guy okay oh
yeah okay we have learned to detect
faces great okay so we go this is
basically but when you want to do the
capture faces and then have your send it
to your machine learning algorithm
basically the best thing that you can do
is to more or less normalize your images
the images that you are going to train
it with and then use the same image
normalization for the faces that you're
trying to recognize right then it will
make your algorithm much much much
better okay so the ones that we will do
here we're going to cut the face we're
going to normalize the pixel intensity
and then we're going to resize the face
image also and okay and if of course you
talk about state of the art this is a
paper in 2014 from a deep face and
basically well that's awesome right they
they they create they just find so many
features in the face right you can see
for example let's say in end and then
rotates the face like if you're if you
are facing like you can see AMG so it's
completely rotated is the same face so
it created the extra part from your skin
that you don't have by doing the what is
it
mirroring maybe from left and right it
creates the part that you're missing and
then it gets you completely in front and
of course if they do this I mean of
course you get super accuracy that's
super nice right we won't do that but
yeah but that's like a state of the art
and then they what they use here of
course is deep learning but their images
they're still normalized okay okay good
so if you want to check that articles
pretty pretty nice
okay so first we're going to just cut
the face and we're going to get only the
80% of the face because here the things
in the back can be noisy of course if
the person has like big ears that will
be a plus but we're going to cut them
yeah well yeah I don't know okay anyway
okay so if you see this result just cuts
the thing oh maybe I did not do this
okay now we're going to normalize the
intensity and for this very easy it's
just this command here equalize equalize
histogram and then we'll just normalize
the face and then for here what I'm
doing is just sending a list of faces of
images and it just returns the list of
images but normal eyes okay and what it
does it it tries to use the complete the
complete grayscale and then by doing
that the contrast of your picture will
be will increase of course right because
imagine that there's difference between
two pixels but it's within certain range
of the holes 0 to 255 and then of course
by extending it then the difference
between those two pixels will increase
so that will increase your contrast and
that will make your features of your
face of course much much better okay so
I think yeah so let's see so for example
this is the picture that I took the last
picture and then is the normal 1 or
normalized so you can see how the
features for example out the eyes now
are much present in the picture also of
the forehead for example it's a bit
light in here and well the lights not
the best but yeah so you can see all
these kind of stuff that gets emphasized
by doing this normalization you can also
normalize the red channel the blue
channel in the green channel so that's
basically what you do with this way
stuff okay and this is basically just to
compare the histogram so that the blue
one is the histogram of the original
picture and the red one
is the histogram of the picture later so
you can see how they completely got
extended and then the features because
of this get more separated the pixel
intensities so now of course is more
prominent things okay so this is just
basically cutting and normalizing the
face just to see the result and then we
can do just resize basically if you have
a real picture bigger then it by Europe
we have here we have different actually
different things to make a bigger or
smaller which is Rick the recommended
one and basically we because we want to
normalize the data set the data set then
we'll just put it 50/50 to yeah 50 by 50
okay so now this is basically the result
of this thing right so this is a 50-50
looks pretty bad but for the algorithm I
hope will be enough okay okay now the
alignment we won't do the alignment but
I will just going to tell you about it
so for example for this you will detect
the face for example and then send that
cut of the face to recognize the eyes
and then once you recognize the eyes of
course you'll have the coordinates and
of course you just create a rotating
matrix for the folder for the numpy
array and then you can rotate this
matrix in order that now you have your
face aligned and now you have a nice
data set foot in this case yeah so it
also works with the opencv and you can
do also the eyes this case we won't do
it this sudden overkill for this thing
but yep
okay so this is just basically bring it
all together useful things
nothing important okay so then we're
going to build our data set so we're
going to of course the tech we're going
to cut it normalize resize and save okay
so now for this yeah let me see okay so
I'm going to take of me so it's just of
course is going to ask my name and then
I used that I use the CV right just
right in a folder you can see here right
so let's see
and you should take around how many
minutes 10 images okay even though it
says 20 but so this is why it six and if
you smile okay and then so just going to
help me yeah
can you okay
come on yeah it is not this is too
simple
okay let me just do this okay
so you have to stand up there you're
probably too tall but yeah put your foot
your name Oh Marcel okay so we'll do
that yeah so yeah get a bit closer I
think just the lightning go go go
just say you have to count in there oh I
can see it of course there oh yeah let's
see that the pictures are not very
accurate fun yeah a very blurry but
let's see it maybe works okay thank you
okay okay let's see okay so I guess
everything this we've done before we
detect the face here of course and then
we just send we checked it for the
length because well there is no length I
don't want to do anything I set a timer
here so it takes about I think every
second or so oh yeah here I said and
then of course a normalised pipeline
that I will define that cutting the
normalizing of the histogram and the
resizing of course and then we'll
basically okay so we're okay okay so
we're done okay so now let's build them
up this is the same function that we
defined before I don't separate the
things because if it breaks like for the
camera thing I have to start over so
that's why it makes a big ones so sorry
anyway so you have three options with
OpenCV you have eigenfaces feature faces
and Elbe pH so
linear binary patterns I will try to
explain more or less how they work and
there are very simple functions and what
you pass these things is just basically
just set on images and we will see how
that works
okay so eigenfaces again faces what it
does is if you think about an image
let's say 100 by 100 then you think
about each pixel being a dimension then
of course these pictures lies in a
10,000 dimensional space and so of
course perhaps not all dimensions are
useful well obviously not so then it
performs basically a PCA what is
basically the constructs the akin
vectors of these things and yeah and
only it interprets like only a few
dimensions account for the most of the
information right ok and I hope
everybody's comfortable with this
information
ok yeah so this a bit of linear algebra
I don't know well I'll do very fast ok
so the example let's take a data set of
4 400 images and then of course if you
what you want to create is that this
product here right but then you you have
a problem right because well you can see
the size of the matrix but instead you
can for any algebra you can take
basically this opposite let's say let's
call it opposite product instead right
and then you can you can recover the
original eigenvector by multiplying by
the initial matrix and this is like a
nice game well a nice trick in order to
not have to compute this thing all these
eigen vectors of this gigantic matrix
and this one that you compute taken
pictures off is basically a 400 by 400
right because you have the transpose of
it so ok sorry that's more or less it's
a trick so you can use it also for other
stuff right if you have matrix that you
want to find the PCA or the or
or taking pictures or all this kind of
stuff you can use that trick basically
many of the libraries use this trick but
just just in the back okay okay and then
of course it projects the eigenvectors
projects all the samples in the pca
subspace and then projects also the
sample in the pca subspace and then
calculates the difference in that
subspace like with all the images in the
images in the image that is a closest
one because you gave a label before that
flags like that's label okay
flag it like that so imagine it yeah
well imagine like hyper dimensional
space and then you have one point in the
other and you have all this only or your
training all the pictures from your
training data and there are around there
somewhere and then you have the sample
here and then it calculates the distance
just by basically just with the back to
distance and then basically that it
reflects the closest one okay so you see
you've seen this I think many times so
this is the reconstruction of a face
just getting more Aiken vectors right
you can see well then not all of them
are necessary of course I think you've
seen this before but the problem with
aching victors it encodes a lot of the
illumination right and then it because
it does not group the eigenvectors in
different like in different labels it
just puts them all in the same space its
regards which features are important for
each group right it's just what it does
it identify the features for all groups
for all labels and then by doing that
then it's just of course if you have a
certain light in certain amount of
pictures it doesn't mean that is useful
for the algorithm will be useful
information because that's what defines
maybe your data set and it will use it
okay okay the other one is Fisher phases
and okay
and this the uses linear discriminant
analysis and basically was proposed in
1936 and this is a little bit different
so it groups them first
he groups the labels first and then once
they're group it tries to identify the
features that are important for each
group not for different not for all of
them but just
for each move the features and then it
tries to want you send a sample picture
it raises it it tries these features
specifically for that a specific group
and then you can of course it will be
much more accurate right than they want
before mm-hmm yeah and it removes like
the variance from from light for example
okay oh yeah let's hear what it just
explained okay so it uses yeah using
some other now it uses that the of
course the dimensionality reduction the
reduction but then the features are per
class okay so and it's a similar it's a
bit more difficult to see because now
they are they are dependent on the class
that they belong to but all gives you an
idea more or less and this is basically
the eigenvectors and this is basically
the reconstruction like you've if you
would do it in the same way of the of
the other egg and faces and now this is
a basic a benchmark for performance but
what it uses a 18t face database that
you can just find online if you want to
try your own maybe if you do something
with deep learning or something right
okay okay this is what the egg and face
of sorry the AT&T database looks like so
it's pretty yeah it's pretty common
pretty pretty easy too if you have you
do this with a really high accuracy okay
you're ready to go to the next one that
is basically identifying faces in the
wild and that's what the deep face does
so it can be like a stadium or a crowd
it doesn't really matter or there is
like behind a window or something and it
recognizes them so if you if you deal
with this and it works very well and
switch to the faces in the wild just if
you type that so the next one is the OB
Peh faces okay so that what this has is
don't look at the whole image but then
look at patterns inside like specific
places of the image and then what it
does basically you get the pixel in the
middle and then you create a threshold
for all the other ones right if it's
bigger you flag it as a one if it's
smaller if like this as a zero right you
can see here
right and then you turn that binary
number into a decimal and the US sign
instead and now instead of assigning
let's say that pixel you assign that
decimal that corresponds to that to that
binary number and by doing that you can
identify certain patterns on the image
that were not recognized before by the
other ones and what it does for example
it does this kind of feature a circle
feature identification if you call it so
for example you become a line and answer
corner or spot this is the basic ones
and say yeah and then this is for
example this is the example of pictures
right and then by applying the local
binary parents it turns into this so
pretty weird but okay
and it's pretty robust as you can see
against this kind of lightnings leave
you if you have a different lining
because well you see most most of them
look basically the same if you compare
this one with this one well it's
completely different right okay okay so
let's let's so this is a function that
just goes to the pictures that we just
saved and just put them in a yeah
basically an array of pictures now
that's it and now for the recognizer
just Caltrain you send those pictures
and labels so you send okay this picture
is for this label and this picture is
for that stuff like that okay okay let's
train the models okay pretty fast
well there were only 20 pictures but
they're pretty fast anyway so the models
will train if you see I just created the
object and just send the images and
labels images and labels that's it I'll
do it again
so make sure okay so making a prediction
so if you're using 3.1 you have to
create a what is called this predict
this collector and then send the
collector and then from the collector
you get the confidence and you get the
prediction from 3.0 it's much easier I
don't know what will probably change it
for a reason but
you can just do it like this and
actually I had a bit of a problem
because it broke and I didn't know why
and then I have to really look at the
documentation and the documentation is
not really about three point one in
Python is not really documentation not
so good that will say so I took me some
time to figure out that that was a
problem
so you have to do that okay so let's get
a sample picture let's hope this works
okay so that's my picture that's my
sample okay so now I will try to
recognize that picture that I just took
with the pictures that we just trained
and with the three algorithms with the
Fisher faces with the AEGON faces with
the LB pH and let's see I think okay
good
so it did well okay yeah okay now
confidence what about these countries
what this number mean because it is not
a kind of an a percentage of how
confident I am the conference is
actually the distance to the vector now
in the high dimensional space and yeah
normally they'd all be pH actually
that's that's not exactly yeah it is the
distance to the to the features during
this high dimensional space that
correspond to that class that well that
it design by this selecting the most
prominent features okay so that went
well okay so the last one will hold you
much more so the same features that we
have same functions that we designed
before okay okay so now let's try to do
in a video and let's see how it works
okay so let's we're going to try to help
detect faces normalize them we're going
to train them will be done that so
recognize faces in a live video feed
apply story so this is me with my
girlfriend and a and a commercial or the
discount guys that you can this is I use
the application that I made so you can
freely use and yeah you want to do for
something else doesn't matter I don't
care okay anyway okay let's see here
so okay yeah so now it I trained them a
I trained them again because we'll send
you a notebook so and now we're going to
call the camera and let's see so okay so
now basically what I do here is just the
same thing but it's inside like the
functions so to take the prediction out
and then just draw a rectangle and I
believe I yeah I put the name of
whatever the recognized person is so
Marcel is it possible way you come here
okay so that's me and I hope it I hope
it works go yeah okay maybe also that's
too high they work so yeah yeah we're so
similar it just - just yeah of course
anyway
it went pretty well I had to stand like
it my toes or something okay pretty good
so let's see how we okay so we have a
bit more okay so like I told you now
we're going to set threshold here and
then the tres hold basically I gonna use
I believe LV pH and the threshold more
or less is by trial and error I cannot
really tell you how much it will work
but if you put it in a condition you by
training and more or less looking around
more or less
I think 140 if someone really different
comes it will flag it I'll need the help
of some other person yeah you're too
similar but let's see let's see what it
let's see what happens okay let's see
okay okay so maybe it's let's see yeah
yeah just come here ah nice no no you
see it so similar to Marcel come closer
yeah yeah yeah okay yeah so they left
work so the church work is more or less
trial and error if you if I put it maybe
lower it will be better because it was
flying it as Marcel okay and then okay
now of course
this won't really be let's see okay so
now if you see you I just changed
they're basically the two number one
right and now it's let's see maybe you
need to change maybe hey didn't it take
Marcel ah come on anyway
alright someone someone looked like me
apparently Oh anyway let's see let's see
wait and see if I go here ah delight
maybe huh
yeah that's fine doesn't recognize he's
daddy okay anyway okay don't be scared
I'm not taking pictures or anything okay
so if you think about it well you can do
a lot of stuff with this oh oh yeah okay
and then of course wanna do this it's
very hurtful really hopeful then also
define this function that is basically
does recognition that's his own stuff
and then hopefully this will work
yeah so now we're gonna do the different
threads and we're gonna in one thread
one I use one camera the other thread
when I use the outer camera he somebody
has another one I can just use one
another one and then of course you can
do maybe a whole image something like
that so of course you can think about
basically Sibelius thing or you can
install maybe one in your I don't know
you have a children you want to put it
in your house and you want to see if he
comes near the door or something like
that right and they can flag right
because you can recognize the objects so
so that's pretty good and you can
basically plug in whatever you want and
I will work okay no no not for you ah
man anyway okay so almost yeah
oh let me just go back okay okay
and thank you I have to show you the
other one but well time okay so anyway
that was basically I thought I couldn't
we have time but okay let's go to do
this thing with the data of the heart
let's see how that works that basically
is notebook 5 okay let's see oh this
thing still okay so we're going to use
pandas for this of course
okay so let's support this thing okay so
now this data it has 32 now has 32
columns but the first column is
basically an ID of of the entrance
whatever like you've also database and
the second ID is basically if it's a
benign or bad malignant see I begin with
an M so anyway didn't got it okay so
it's basically the data set and so he
has 569 entrance of the data and then
what I do is just collect basically the
labels that was like I told you the
first second column because well Python
starts counting from zero and I drop the
first two because they're not important
and then I basically yeah at some I put
input here the labels just to see more
or less what is in there so these are
the labels and that is more or less the
proportion it's also 357 so by doing
this value counts like can you know that
but okay
357 benign and 212 Jesus milene I'm
sorry okay so what I'm going to do here
then I don't know if it's actually good
or not so I'm gonna normalize all the
engines
like if there were pixels from 0 to 200
and 255 there is very similar what you
do when you have like different features
that have different scales right because
I don't really look I took this data set
because from the I don't know cui
website or something this because it
didn't had missing values then you have
to lose time in reshaping the data so I
just grabbed the first one that he said
no missing values and around nice amount
of features so that's why I grabbed it I
don't really have no idea what they are
ok so so why doing that will basically
do what what what what normally is done
to normalize it but instead instead
where I'm just going to 255 and then
let's see I really don't know how this
will perform at really have no idea okay
oh not in the presentation ok so now of
course I take of course I'm going to
take a random sample to train my
algorithm and basically then I take my
validation database sorry data frame
here ok and then let's see the
proportion okay so it takes 400 and the
proportion it's more or less point 60 62
percent so I hope it performs better
than 62 percent right no I really don't
know sometimes it does sometimes it
doesn't
ok so let's see so then what I do
oh I'm not in the presentation mode come
on
oh yeah here ok ok so now what I do is
okay so I have this this string of 30 30
characters sorry 30 features right and
then ok let's put it back like if it was
an image like we took so lets reshape it
for 6 to 5 right and that will be shaped
as if it was an image and then what I'm
going to do then also for the training
and the validation 1 okay and then
basically what I'm going to show change
because it also receives as a label only
numbers like 0 and 1 so I'm going to put
1 of course to them a ling and b9 nice
to the to the 0 so just changing that
and I'm going to do just open the
face recognizer why this one I don't
know but let's just do this one and then
you can set here the number of
components so but then she's going to
choose then that means the number of
eigenvectors that you're going to use
and then we're going to train it okay
and then here it goes so now we're going
to call the collector and then I going
to go and try to identify with the with
my story with my with all the validation
data and then we're going to see which
ones got correctly and then just going
to make a counter and then I'm gonna
make the proportion I have no idea
probably I hope doesn't do that bad
so here goes yeah not so good that's so
good but you can see the idea can
somebody tell me why doesn't work that
well because the idea of a vacant
vectors you know you have a system you
can always decompose and eigenvectors so
you have similar systems right it should
work why doesn't perform that bad what
was so the main difference with with the
pictures you think about it the pictures
that ones that we used right now was 50
by 50 right so that's that's two
thousand and five hundred features so
that means it's a space of two thousand
twenty five hundred dimensional space
and our data was twenty right so you can
see the difference right in this case we
have thirty and we have around five
hundred right so what happens there is
that like imagine now if I only have one
dimension and then I have a lot of
points in those dimensions right so
they're gonna and I only restrict them
to from 0 to 255 I clock them right so
they're going to be very close together
then when I send them my sample yeah of
course it's going to fail right but I
can assure you if you find the sample
that there has a lot of features and not
so many examples it will perform much
better because of this reason because
then you have a very high dimensional
space and then these points will kind of
cluster in the correct way and then it
will perform better and that's why
in my opinion is not performing the rest
and now yep
I guess thank you and that's it